obviously it's somebody who uh
uh never really made afrobeats but to
see as an African
um to see it be I mean I I just talked
to somebody last night uh Burna Boy was
the number one song in urban radio and
it got overtaken by Thames right see
which is so fire right which is so far
man
um how dope is it just to see afrobeat
be like uh the new just it's kind of
like what everyone's doing even if
you're not from like it's just a it's
just music now it's not an African music
yeah and that was one of those fights
yeah yeah one of our biggest fights was
just introducing it into the you know
into the world and then once it was
introduced okay don't quite generalize
it because I remember when we was first
you know I remember that when I was
trying to um shop whiz kid over at Sony
and this is like 2000 10.
if people don't know whiz kids like a OG
everybody thought it was I mean they
thought it was reggae music right but at
that time it wasn't no information so
you didn't you never really knew but
ultimately it was always a fight but
then when it worked in the UK it opened
up the door and then when YouTube became
super popular
that's what did it social media and
YouTube is what opened the doors for
afrobeat to actually shine yeah cause
YouTube is the biggest uh platform
people consume music on in Africa right
it's there in uh I think it's Audiomack
is there too because it doesn't take a
lot of bandwidth yeah Audi Max it's huge
in Africa yeah so you were [ __ ] with
uh Wizkid in 2010 yeah was he signed to
you or were you just helping him out I
signed him in 2008. so you signed
whiskey in 08 yeah that's crazy back in
the way to con lever to convict no
that's that's convict Africa wow so how
well just explain it because now he's a
he's a global Superstar oh he's super
super gold uh so you sign him
um obviously he was probably buzzing
where he's from like how did you guys
initially meet yeah and what ended up
what ended up happening well so what
happened was when we when I went to
Africa after the World Cup we were
looking for ways that we can take the
local music and Branch it off right so
at that time it was the local music was
so traditional musically that it
wouldn't break outside of Nigeria Ghana
anywhere right so we started adding like
commercialized music and music like
instruments around it like we
commercialized a lot of it so it went
from afrobeat to afro pop wow basically
yeah you follow so once we did that then
we signed we signed it which kit first
then after that was another group called
P-Square okay P-Square was two twins
that came out of Nigeria they ended up
becoming the poster Childs of Africa at
that time as a group they were the
biggest streaming selling all of that
but that was all of us pushing that
point wow as that went more popular
Wizkid as a solo artist just became
bigger and bigger because he had the the
whole
um fell off Vibe like the younger
generation swag wow you know so as I
started moving everything else started
branching as we went as we were signing
acts and pushing them over then it was
like okay soon now that this is huge in
Africa let's start chopping it and
chopping It in America right and that's
when all the other records started
coming about but we just couldn't get
the Us labels to catch they didn't get
it yet you were ahead of your time yeah
they didn't get it you know they didn't
it really kind of took the UK hopping on
board and then I really feel like I
played a huge role when Drake did one
dance because Drake was so heavily
influenced about what was going on in
the UK and afrobeats but I feel like one
dance made like um America okay with the
sound they're like oh Drake did you know
what I mean I feel like labels look at
[ __ ] in the shallow way like that yeah
the labels probably looked at the
success of the one dance with Drake and
then but Drake was on yeah Drake already
knew how big it was that's why he did in
the first place like he already knew
what it was so what ended up having to
happen with you and Wiz Kids so so
ultimately right now Wiz is no longer
signed to us okay but we're still
Affiliates and work all his records
internationally along with Sunday at
what point in time did you guys split on
the label side um Ten Years After wow
like 2018. oh [ __ ] yeah that's not I
think I interviewed him in 2018. yeah
right around the corner I think he was
on my show there if he was in LA he was
the reason why he got here oh wow that's
crazy that was that was his first run in
in the U.S are you still getting a piece
of whiz kid Paul no no no no no no no
no no but but the kind of relationship
we have with all of our artists even
after they're no longer on the label we
still bring work and there's still
commission from it so I always try to
keep a relationship to where it's not a
a boss employee type of you know
relationship it's always been a
partnership yeah and oftentimes there's
certain things that we as convict music
just do better than anybody else so they
always come to us for certain services
and we always be attached to them